okay so welcome to this live stream
we're gonna be doing another SAT math
question-and-answer session if you're
watching this end replay the the
playback there's a lot of good value
usually delivered in these live streams
with commenters jumping in on the live
stream chatting and asking some really
excellent questions so you know take a
look at some of the problems we're gonna
be going through here together and then
also pay attention to some of the
questions that come later from the
members that jump on the live chat and
have some great questions so I think
what I'm going to do is just get right
started into this live stream again the
way to get the most out of this as usual
is just a you know ask questions and you
know participate in live stream as much
as you can and then another thing that
you can do is help each other out so you
know I'm not able to maybe reply right
away to a particular question but if you
can help each other out
you know you'll all get you'll all get
the best results from this live stream
so the other thing is if everyone could
just let me know can you hear me okay
can you see okay is everything all right
we're gonna get started in just a second
we're gonna do some three example
problems I prepared for you and then
we're gonna open it up for question and
answers so okay so we're sounding good
okay so welcome to everybody that's
joined so far again keep your keep your
questions in mind and we're going to
talk about some of these different
problems so I was working with a student
just recently and we were going through
some problems together and I know these
are some problems that show up on the
SAT exam and so I just want to kind of
show you see if you can solve these okay
I'm gonna start off by writing this
first one down so if 3y over 8x is equal
to 5 over 6 right what is the value ok
the value of x divided by Y question
mark so what do you think so how would
you solve this problem see if you can do
it on your own and you know see if you
what you get for an answer and then go
ahead and feel free to jump in here what
do you think we should do to solve this
one
so this is basically you know just an
equation that they're giving us you know
they're telling us 3y over 8x equals
five-sixths and they're asking us what's
the value of x divided by y hmm well
what do you think any ideas anybody has
some suggestions what we should do this
is a typical problem you know one that
shows up a little bit earlier in the
test it's pretty straightforward but
sometimes it stumps students it's in
some type of form like this where
they're asking you for a variation on
what they're giving you here so any
ideas anybody want to jump in and let us
know what do you think you would do
first to solve this you know what's the
value of x divided by Y okay Bob is
saying is it 0.45 okay what do you think
is he is he right it's Bob right well
let's take a look so that our goal here
is to get Y over x over Y but right now
you can see we have Y over X right so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
flip the left side of the equation over
but if I do that to the left side I have
to do that to the right side right so
that's just one of the properties of
proportions if you take the reciprocal
the left you want to take the reciprocal
the right now the thing is is we want to
end up with just this part right here X
divided by Y right so how do we get rid
of that 8/3 what do we have to do to get
rid of the 8/3 well you could divide by
8/3 but sometimes it's easier just to
multiply by the reciprocal so I'm gonna
multiply both sides by 3/8 see how the
3s cancel and the eights cancel a
numerator and denominator so now you can
see we're looking at 18 over 40 which
reduces down to what 9 over 20 which
equals what Bob was saying point 4 5 so
that's exactly right so yeah good
question so as we're going through this
if you're just joining us you know we're
doing that QA but I'm just going to kick
it off with some just some examples here
just some typical SAT questions so the
next one okay that we're going to take a
look at and go down here and we're gonna
look at this one so see they give you a
compound inequality like this they say
if negative 3 is less than Y is less
than 5 right
and four is less than X is less than
seven okay what are the possible okay
what are the possible integer values of
x minus y question mark so what do you
think so they're giving us two compound
inequalities if Y is between negative 3
& 5 X is between 4 & 7 okay not
including negative 3 & 5 not including 4
& 7 right what are the possible integer
values of X minus y so we're what we're
looking for here now a lot of times in
the tests there's a multiple choice
section they would give you some options
and you could you know check through
them but here I'm going to give you a
hint you know the answer is actually
going to be an interval okay just like
these are intervals so we want to look
at what is the smallest value that X
could wat X minus y it could be and we
also want to look at what the maximum or
the largest value is and then we know
that X minus y has to be in between that
minimum and maximum value so so let me
ask you a question what do you think the
minimum value would be what do you think
the the smallest that X minus y could be
so let's write this down here so X minus
y any ideas okay Bob is saying 7 okay
and he's get a question mark here well
let's see the smallest value okay
especially says she if I'm probably
pronouncing that wrong proud is saying 6
okay hmm good good question so what do
you think what's gonna be the smallest
value well I'm gonna give you a little
hint okay so you see the negative 3 here
see how Y has to be greater than
negative 3 so that means that this could
when we're talking about integer values
it can't equal negative 3 so the
smallest this could be would really be
like negative 2 the larger this Y value
could be as far as an integer goes is
going to be positive 4 same thing with X
over here that the smallest it could be
is 3 the largest it could be a 6 now if
you want to find the smallest value when
you take the X's minus the Y's that's
going to occur when you take the
smallest value for X minus the largest
value for y so 3 minus 4 that's actually
going to give us the smallest value of
negative 1 okay Bob is asking isn't the
smallest X that can be is 5 let's see so
X is between 4 & 7 okay and Y is between
negative 3 & 5 and we're looking for the
integer values of X minus y so the
difference between X minus y so the key
is you want to take the smallest value
here minus the largest value here so 4 3
minus four is giving us negative 1 so
now what's the maximum value that X
minus y can be what do you guys think
what's the what's the largest that it
could be hmm we're almost there we've
got our interval got our smallest value
here we're trying to find our largest
values here
okay sessi is saying 4 Bob is saying but
3 is not greater than negative 4 oh I'm
sorry oh I made a mistake you're
absolutely right this is 5 okay whoops I
made a mistake
so you're right so it's actually 5 minus
4 is positive 1 okay there you go and
let's see now yield lakhani is saying
the minimum value is positive 5 okay
well let's see so to find the maximum
value you have to take the maximum over
here 6 minus the smallest value over
here 6 minus negative 2 is how much it's
going to be 8
okay so again this was a tricky question
and we're getting a lot of comments in
the comments box and that's that's
really good because the thing is it's
tricky I mean this is a tricky problem a
lot of students get this one wrong but
basically we're saying that x and y are
integers okay so we're starting with
that assumption and we're trying to find
out what's the smallest that X minus y
can be what's the largest that X minus y
can be and then we're looking for the
possible values you know in between okay
those two extremes so the way you're
gonna get the smallest values are gonna
take the what you're gonna take here
this you get the small stuff going to
take this the smallest over here - the
largest over here so we're doing X minus
y so 5 minus 4 is going to give us
positive 1 and then to get the largest
value we're gonna take the largest over
here minus the smallest over here so 6
minus negative 2 is giving us positive 8
so this was definitely a challenging
problem go ahead and think about it a
little bit more but let's jump into the
third question that I prepared for us
today and then remember we're gonna open
this up for us in Q&A so if you have
some other questions you know we can
talk about them here together okay so
this one see if you can get this one so
they're gonna give us a system of
equations you know systems right so
systems is like two or more equations
and what we're gonna do is we're going
to solve this system but what I'm gonna
do I'm just going to kind of read this
to you we're gonna find the value of C
okay this is C over here so find the
value of C such that the system has two
solutions right - two answers right so
what do you think go ahead and tackle
that one what would you do to solve for
C I'll get this constant right here so
that when you solve this you get
actually two answers now I'll give you
some hints just when you're when you're
thinking about this so first of all this
top equation notice it's a quadratic see
it's x squared so what type of a graph
is an x squared okay Bob is saying would
you do the discriminant and set greater
than zero that's exactly that's exactly
right Bob because we want to do the
discriminate okay
plug X -1 in for y yeah that's exactly
right okay so you're going to take the X
minus 1 we're going to put it in for y
so that's a substitution method right so
we've got X minus 1 equals 3 x squared
plus 2 X plus C what would you do from
there so Bob is telling us about the
discriminant and we did the substitution
here so what would you do next well the
next step okay when you do the
discriminate you want to get everything
on one side of the equation and set it
to zero okay so that's right says he's
saying you know get like terms yeah
that's exactly right so you want to get
the everything on one side so I'm going
to subtract X from both sides so k-pops
is set equal to zero that's right so
that's going to be three x squared
subtract X from both sides that's +1 x
and then we're going to add one which is
going to give us C plus one now remember
when you do the discriminant who
remembers what the discriminant is
remember the formula for the
discriminant well when you have an
equation like this right ax squared plus
BX plus C the discriminant is actually
what there we go bob says b square minus
4ac yeah that's exactly right so b
squared minus 4ac and if you want
okay guys still with me okay so sorry
about that so basically what we have to
do now is we have to identify our a B
and C so we've got a is 3 B is positive
1 and C is this whole quantity C plus 1
that's our constant right so what we've
got is B squared is 1 squared minus 4
times a which is 3 times
our C value which is C plus 1 and we
want that to be greater than 0
okay so let's simplify this down a
little bit more okay
and let's see we've got 1 minus 12 C
minus 12 is greater than 0 let's see
we've got negative 12 C what do we have
1 minus 12 is negative 11 I'm going to
add that to the other side make that
positive 11 and then now we have to
solve for C we're going to divide by
negative 12 and is this going to be a
greater than sign greater than or equal
to less than or less than or equal to C
the the thing that they're testing us
out in this question is that yeah less
than Bob says because when you divide or
multiply by a negative and remember that
inequality yep so she says flip it
that's exactly right so when you
multiply or divide by negative sign
changes direction mm-hmm okay and that's
right so now ye'll says C is less than
negative 11 twelfths yep and that's
exactly right and that's what we're
getting right here
so as long as C is less than that value
then you're going to get two solutions
so again this was just testing us on the
discriminant and it was testing us on
how to work with inequalities and it was
taught the testing us on some solvent
you know systems of equations so three
really good questions if you understand
those I mean those are going to be some
easier questions to get right when you
take the SAT so who's taking the SAT
coming up here on the 26th is everyone
getting ready for the 26th exam
yeah who's taking it on the next ok
ssese says she is okay great awesome
very good so one thing I wanted to let
everyone you know about kabobs taking
October 7th if you're preparing and
you're looking for some additional help
I just wanted to let everybody know
about my two courses so I've got one
course that's
for the a CT and one for the SAT and
these are the math sections so with the
act1 I go through 65 concepts and with
the SAT when I go through 39 concepts so
it's a video course and you can check it
out there's three free previews for both
courses I've got a link in the
description of this video so if you go
to the description click on that link
there you can check it out and see if
it's something that you'd be interested
in a lot of students have taken it and
if told me that it's helped them boost
their scores on the SAT so definitely
worth checking out so go ahead and check
the link in the description after this
live stream but for right now what do
you think so now we're opening it up for
some some QA what kinds of things would
you like to talk about any questions you
want to discuss all case assess he's
saying what was the type of math problem
that you solved in the second example
with possible values okay here let's
flip back back to that one for a second
so you know I BRE v-eight addthis a
little bit I got this from one of the
other practice tests one of the other
SAT practice tests so I abbreviate the
the wording a little bit but basically
you know this is testing us on you know
working with compound inequalities and
it was a little bit of an abstract
problem because you know we had to find
like basically a range of values so yeah
so you might want to kind of scan
through some of the practice tests on
the SAT that the College Board website
for some of these inequality type
problems this is challenging you know
that's why I wanted to bring it up today
but yeah other questions you want to
talk about more what do you guys you
guys have some questions for me
okay so Bob's asking a good one let's
see here Bob so you've got X plus 4
times 2x minus a and let's see what do
you have here is equal to 0 and you're
wondering how to find a okay that's a
good question so alright so what do you
guys think so what would you what would
you do to solve this to solve this any
ideas well the problem with this one Bob
if I can just kind of jump in here is
that see when you have two variables so
we have X as a variable and a as of
variable you need actually two equations
to solve now if you want to solve for a
in terms of X you know that's an option
but I maybe need to know a little bit
more about this one but but you know if
we were just gonna go through the
motions here we could like foil it out
or distribute so we could say you know
two x squared minus a X let's see what
else do we have here yeah okay again you
know is saying x equals negative four
yeah that's actually one of the
solutions that's exactly right see the
other solution would be is going to be a
equals two X because the idea here is
that you set each of these factors equal
to zero and solve that's called the zero
product property so so that's basically
when it's in factored form like that all
you have to do is make two two equations
X plus four equals zero to x minus a
equals zero and solve but I need to know
a little bit more about maybe the
wording on that one Bob so I thought
that helps you a little bit but okay
other questions other things did you
guys would like to talk about more like
how'd you do on the okay si si saying
when do you use the discriminant okay
good question okay rational equations
okay yeah so as far as when you use the
discriminant how many solutions are you
guys with me I think I'm having a little
trouble at the connection so yeah so
basically use the discriminant you're
trying to find the number of solutions
so you know b squared minus 4ac is the
discriminant if you guys know your
quadratic formula right the b square
minus 4ac is that part that shows up
underneath the square root you know so
basically you use that when you're
trying to just analyze the number of
solutions so if this is zero you're
going to get how many solutions and if
it's positive how many solution if it's
negative how many solutions well if it's
zero you're going to get one if it's
negative you're going to get no real
solution so you're going to get two
imaginary solutions and if it's positive
you're going to get two real solutions
so yeah so you might wanted to review
the discriminant a little bit so yeah so
other questions the other thing is
everyone would like to talk a little bit
more about what do you think so we've
talked about Oh okay so let's see so
yeah so somebody was at
thing about rational equations so do you
have a particular Collette she do you
have a particular rational equation in
mine that you want to talk about so you
know rational just means ratio right so
like if you had something like I'll just
give you a really basic example okay
well here I'll give you a little more
challenging example like say for example
if it was like this Plus this okay let's
see okay there are some questions coming
in about matrices and vectors no I don't
think so much with vectors but sometimes
with matrices there can be a question
about that just a real basic question
just either like adding subtracting or
multiplying you know matrices and we can
talk about we can talk about that too so
I'm just making this up off the top of
my head so this might not be the best
question but when you solve rational
equations like what you want to think
about is like what's the common
denominator and you want to clear those
denominators so for example on this one
what could you multiply by to clear the
denominators any ideas what do you think
so if you're gonna multiply to clear the
denominators what's the common
denominator any thoughts on that one
so what do you think what's the common
denominator well see here you've got X
minus 3 here you have X plus 3 here you
have x squared minus 9 Cady is saying X
minus 3 okay let's see so we're looking
for the common denominator if i factor
this guy over here see how we're getting
X plus 3 X minus 3 okay yeah there you
go so my men Agitos saying X plus 3 and
X minus 3 yeah that's exactly right so
what you would do then is you would
multiply through all the terms you take
this common denominator you distribute
it to all the groups they're all the
terms and what that does is it clears
the denominators so then you can go
ahead and solve now you won't have any
fractions so if I was going to do that
when I distribute here to see how the X
minus 3s cancel so you just end up with
x times X plus 3 right and over here the
X plus 3s cancel so you're going to end
up with 4 times X minus 3 and then over
here both the X plus 3 and X
mistreat cancel and you're just left
with eight so now you've cleared the
denominators you know it's easier to
solve but the main thing you want to be
careful of is you can't divide by zero
so if X comes out to three or negative 3
then that's going to be what they call
an extraneous root and you want to just
you know toss that one aside so that
that's not one of the answers so that's
basically a basic overview of just like
how to solve these equations and it's
it's about getting that common
denominator and then multiplying through
okay let's see broth Obama's saying John
and Sally spent a hundred twenty hours
completing a project if Sally spent
thirty more hours working on the project
than John did how many hours did John
spend okay so what do you think about
that one so so let's see so basically
broth Obama's as asking this question it
sounds like a system of equations so
let's let's see if we can write down
what he said and see if you guys can
solve this okay and think of other
questions you want to ask me maybe the
more specific you can be I found that
kind of works out a little bit better
because then I can kind of address you
know address what you're asking a little
bit better so okay so let's see so we've
got okay so let's see so John is Pitt
Sally spend 120 hours completing a
project so let's just write that down
120 and Sally spent 30 more hours than
John right so basically if you think
about this it's like here's Sally's
hours here's John hours and they add up
to 120 but Sally
spent the number of hours at John spent
plus 30 more right so okay so then Bob
says I got 45 and yeah isn't that just a
system of equations yeah you're right
okay very yeah very good so the thing is
when you solve these systems of
equations you know you've got a couple
options and we did earlier we talked
about substitution but let's maybe
rearrange this one so we can talk about
elimination so say for example if I
subtract J from both sides of this
equation we get s minus J equals 30
right so now if we were to add these two
equations together what do we get - s
the J's cancel we get 150
and s is equal to 75 right so now if you
put 75 back in over here for s and solve
for J you get 45 or same thing over here
if you use this original equation you
get 45 so yeah so basically that's a
substitution elimination systems of
equations it's definitely important on
the SAT so you might want to review that
if you're studying but other questions
other questions you want to talk about I
let me look back in the chat here so
yeah so other things you want to ask
about somebody was asking about an
outlier and probability so I think when
you're talking about outliers like you
know I can tell you a little bit about
that like if you've ever worked with the
box-and-whisker plots have you ever you
guys ever graph the box and whisker
plots so the idea is like if you were to
take this range here this is what they
call the inner quartile range okay so
it's basically the third quartile minus
the first quartile and if you multiply
that by 1.5 okay and if you add it to
this third quartile okay if there's
points that are further to the right of
that point that's considered an outlier
or if you subtract one and a half this
inner quartile range from the first
quartile any points that are lower that
those are considered outliers so that's
that's box and whiskers but you know
basically when you're just looking at
the data if you see a point that's like
way you know higher than all the rest or
way lower than all the rest you know
typically that you can you can say
that's an outlier okay so Bob's asking
about can you explain standard deviation
okay so let's see so standard deviation
yeah sure definitely and the difference
between greater deviation and less okay
well the only thing I really can maybe
speak to as far as deviation standard
deviation goes is is basically this okay
so the standard deviation is an idea
okay not an idea but it's a it's an
indication of how spread out the data
points are from the average from the
mean right so the larger the standard
deviation is the more the data points
are going to be spread out from the mean
so like an example and the smaller the
closer they are to the means for example
if in your test
so Colette she is asking about the
rational equations yeah you might want
to check back to that one that we were
doing just a little earlier the rational
equation one that's a good example maybe
review that one but basically yeah so
for example if you took a quiz like in
your class and say for example everybody
got like seven seven eight eight eight
you know just an example so you can see
here like you know everybody is
basically getting right around a seven
or an eight okay so you can see this
one's going to have a very small
standard deviation as opposed to like
see another class took the same test and
like somebody got a one and somebody got
a five and somebody got a nine somebody
got a ten and somebody got the extra
credit they got an eleven this is going
to have a much higher standard deviation
now as far as calculating the standard
deviation you know you can use your
calculator for that if it's a calculator
section but I think as far as the SAT is
concerned you're probably not gonna have
to do that just because of the time
constraints they might just ask you more
generally like which ones gonna have a
larger or smaller standard deviation so
I do talk about this in the course that
I mentioned earlier if you guys are
interested in that but it's a little bit
more much to go into right now so let's
see other questions somebody else had a
question about a circle Jake was asking
about the circumference of a circle is
24 PI meters what is the area okay let's
see so see if you guys guys and gals can
figure out this one so let's see what
was that question again so let's see its
circumference is 24 PI meters and they
were asking what the area is yeah I mean
this is a just kind of a pretty good
question just a good introductory
question what do you guys think so any
ideas about how to find the area okay
bob says 144 pi is it okay is he right
well again and I was like you kind of
draw a diagram you know and what's the
formula for circumference
two pi are right so now if you just
substitute alright okay / - okay
so that's right so that means the radius
is 12 okay very good
and so then what's the formula for the
area of a circle PI R squared right so
then all you have to do is put that 12
in for the radius square it times pi so
it's going to be a hundred and
forty-four PI meters squared so yeah so
just some formulas you want to memorize
you know your circumference formula your
area formula you know those are going to
be important so yeah so other questions
other things you guys want to talk about
okay yeah Bob's Bob is really sharp he's
he's quick on these so that's good but
yeah with practice you guys all get
quicker too so have you guys been taking
the practice tests that have been
released by the College Board let's see
have you guys been taking those practice
tests I think there's eight of them up
there now they've got eight practice
tests and those should be pretty
representative of what the actual test
is gonna look like so you know you can
go on there and sizing okay yeah you've
taken those yeah that's that's a really
good way to practice you know take those
tests and go through them and see which
ones you're missing you know again these
courses that I mentioned earlier that
you can check out they talked about a
lot of the underlying concepts so okay
let's see you broth Obama's saying can
you explain a problem with the radians
okay so a problem with radians okay so
let's see so problem with radians so
let's see so when we're talking about
radians the main thing to know with
radians okay just just to make it real
simple here is that PI radians is equal
to what 180 degrees right PI radians is
180 degrees so whenever you see PI you
can replace with 180 degrees so if they
say you know 5 PI over 6
you can put 180 in place of Pi and
simplify 150 right
so yeah so that's basically it so so
let's see yes I have can you make a
video on SAT 5 through 8 math please
Bobby oasiz what happened yes you know
what unfortunately I don't know you know
what's like people are calling me right
now I thought I put my my phone on do
not disturb but apparently it's it's not
but uh yes I apologize about that so
yeah so other questions I don't know if
this answer your question about the
radians but like you know for example OS
s stream offline okay huh it says I'm
online right now I think it just got
interrupted the stream got interrupted
maybe try hitting refresh okay so it's
back on I don't get great ok Colette she
is saying rational equations and
expressions well yeah that I talked
about that one a little bit earlier so
when you talk about rational expressions
you know that's that's like this guy
over here that we were doing earlier so
if you go back to that you can kind of
analyze that a little bit further but
it's all about clearing the denominators
when you're solving those rational
expressions okay yeah so let's see so
other questions so yeah so other
question you want to talk about I notice
you guys are starting to jump in and
help one another that's that's the key
so if somebody wants to maybe help that
person was asking about the rational
equations you know feel free to do that
but other questions that you want to
talk about other things you want to talk
about regarding the SAT okay so study
sites asking about you know what
suggestions we have about timing and the
SAT math you know as far as timing goes
you know it's it's very similar to like
the SAT in the sense that you know the
easier questions tend to be at the
beginning the more difficult questions
tend to be near the end you know there's
two sections but like for each section
it's tends to start easier so you
definitely want to work faster in the
beginning to save yourself some time for
those later questions so yeah so that I
don't that helps you at all but yeah
don't overthink the ones in the
beginning you know but then don't take
for granted the ones a little bit later
because they tend to be a little bit
more more steps you know so you want to
see some time for that so work faster in
the beginning and then and then you'll
have time for those tougher ones okay so
other questions other things you want to
talk about let's see do you think the a
CT math is easier than the SAT math you
know a lot of people are telling me that
they they do think that the a CT math is
easier just because you can use your
calculator throughout the whole entire
test whereas that they know the SAT at
some of its calculator sums not
calculator sums free response you know
where's the a CT it's all
multiple-choice it's all calculator so a
lot of people tend to find that a CT to
be a little bit easier than the SAT so
yeah that's that's my opinion that's
what other people have told me as well
so let's see Bob is asking is there some
type of quadratic equation thing for
cubic equations you know there is a
formula for for that I remember learning
about this when I was in school about a
formula for cubic equations it's quite a
large formula it's not as nice and easy
to work with like the quadratic formula
is but you're not gonna have to worry
about that for the SAT but yeah good
question nonetheless
sanaya is asking how often do you make
these live streams you know I kind of
just want to have the time I'm usually
pretty busy working with students so
sometimes when I have some time I know a
test is coming up you know I'll you know
I'll talk about the course that I put
together to you know promote that of
course and then you know just jump on
and try to help some of my subscribers
you know prepare and that kind of thing
so yeah let's see it does your program
of every concept you need to study or
just 39
well it's broth Obama it's basically 39
concepts that that are basically
important and recurring concepts there's
always like a few little problems that
you know maybe show up on one test and
not the next test
but those 39 were ones that I noticed
came up over and over and over again
throughout you know the the tests that
they've released and so that's why I
focus on those so I mean depending on
where you're at you know I mean if
you're like you know you're like it's
750 or whatever you know you probably
don't need the course if you're at you
know 3 3 400 something like that you're
trying to boost your score you know and
the low-end then this would really
definitely help you that the course go
over those key concepts so
yeah so I think you know Colette she's
asking more some mole questions more
about selected science type questions
you won't have to worry about that for
the math section of SAT and then Jake's
asking can you go over using proportions
to solve problems yeah so when you so
when you talk about proportions you know
what's the proportion so yeah that's a
good question Jake so here let's talk
about proportions see basically a
proportion is what it's a ratio equal to
another ratio right so you know for
example if you can let's say for example
if you were able to make let's say three
dozen cookies and you know 15 minutes
something like this it's like how many
cookies could you make in like four
hours okay like this so a proportion is
just a ratio equal to a ratio but when
you're looking at this question you see
how I kind of put a little twist on it I
said how many cookies can you make in
four hours well notice over here we've
got minutes over here we've got hours
yeah and Bobby write about about the 48
dozen but if you want to find out how
many cookies there's how many in a dozen
there's 16 12 in a dozen hey so 12 in a
dozen so you got to multiply by eight by
yeah so you gotta multiply those
together so you want to make sure when
you're doing those proportions that the
units are the same so to answer your
question Jake like if you have dozens
per minute we're gonna calculate dozens
per minute so like here I would probably
convert this into what is this 4 times
60 240 minutes right like that then when
you get your answer over here you're
gonna actually get the number of dozens
of cookies then you have to convert that
into just actual cookies or what I could
do is I could say well a dozen is 12 so
I'm going to convert this to 36 cookies
right
so now when I cross multiply you know
you can cross multiply and solve a so
you could say 15 times x equals 36 times
240 and then you just divide both sides
by 15 right and then you've got it so
yeah so basically let's see so other
questions let me look back in the chat I
know we've kind of had a little
of some interruptions on this livestream
I apologize about that so nine tickets
it gets a little bit crazy but let's see
what other questions you have so study
sites asking can you make videos for the
SAT practice test math five through
eight you know what you might want to do
is you know can Academy has the
solutions online so if you take the
tests you know they have the solutions
like there's like an online way of
taking the tests they have the solutions
you can check right there for those for
those solutions and they also have the
answers as well and you can also print
out some of the steps too that they
released you know for those tests I
probably recommend recommend checking
that out and Jake's also asking let's
see what books if you do you recommend
for studying for the SAT math you know
Princeton usually puts out a pretty good
book you could check that one out that
seems to be kind of a middle-of-the-road
but there's like Princeton Kaplan Barron
but maybe Princeton would probably be a
good place to start if you're looking
for extra problems and whatnot let's see
Bob was asking about inverse proportions
Oh Bob can you tell me more about the
inverse proportions what did you mean
when you meant when you when you said
that so inverse proportions
maybe tell me more about that and let's
see breath Obama what how would I
improve on problems where you have to
come up with an equation ooh that's a
good question so yeah so you know the
thing is you want to be able to
translate those word problems into
equations so it depends you know it
depends on the problem whether it's you
know whether it's I mean is it like the
one you're asking earlier we were asking
about the system of equation one with
with the two ages and are the two amount
of work hours yeah let's see that's a
tough one I love it it's just practice
you know practice picking out the
important information let's see which of
the following is equivalent to nine
raised to the power of three over four
okay let's look at that study site let's
see if we can do that problem so let's
see so nine raised to the power of three
over four okay let's see and we're
wondering what's that equal to is it 3
square root 9 4 root
9 root 3 3 root 3 oh I see what you're
saying you're saying I get wrong
question so you're saying 9 to the 3/4
power ok ok this is interesting here let
me grab another sheet of papers so all
right as everyone familiar with rational
equations and not rational equations and
rational exponents rational exponents
rational just means fractional right so
it was a fractional exponent so 9 to the
3/4 power well here's the thing
see bob says square root of 9 to the 3rd
okay good yeah good question so
basically yeah this is a good question
so when you look at 9 9 is 3 squared
right okay and then what do you do when
you have a power to a power so you
multiply right so this is 3 to the 6
force which is really equal to 3 to the
3 halves right which is really like
let's see that's really like 3 cubed but
then you're taking the square root so
the key here is really remember that the
denominator is the the root and the
numerator here is the power okay but you
can simplify the website I've meant to
put this 2 over here so yeah so
basically what you can do is you can
pull out a 3 here so this is going to be
3 square root of 3 so so I don't you
want to check that again so basically
what I what did I do I said let's go
ahead and write 9 as 3 squared and a
power to power you multiply right then I
reduce that fraction and then just
remember that this denominator right
here that's the route that goes there ok
and then the numerator that's the power
that goes there and then you can
simplify from there okay so that helped
you study site ok great
ok so yeah there's more than one right
ready to answer Bob sometimes what you
just have to look at the multiple choice
and pick the best one but this is a
pretty simplified version you know but
sometimes they might put it in a
slightly different form so you have to
check to see what the equivalent you
know the equivalent ones it would be
okay so other questions I think we only
have about three people with us at the
moment so kind of a smaller group I
think people people kind of jump
and then kind of jumped off but other
questions for those that are here that
you know maybe you want to ask me some
more questions so maybe what I'll just
kind of just say in the moment while
you're thinking of those questions is
you know if you're interested I've got a
link in the description of this video so
you can check out my two courses I've
got a huge a CT math review video course
and that goes through 65 concepts that
you want to know for the test and a huge
SAT math review video course and that
goes through 39 concepts that are
important so this goes through kind of
like the underlying important things you
want to know so check those video
courses out there's three free previews
so if you go over there and just just
want to see what it's like and see if
it's right for you you can still benefit
from those three free previews on both
those courses so yeah go ahead and check
out the link in the description and see
if that's something that you're
interested in but yeah other questions
other things you want to talk about
right now just on this live stream I
just I know the test is coming up for a
lot of students so that's why I thought
I'd jump on here okay so Jake is asking
a question here let's see Jake we've got
3x minus y equals 12 and let's see hold
on a second but a lot of technical
difficulties today right okay sorry
about that so and then what is this is 8
to the X power
oops / Oh 2 to the Y oh okay okay
yeah this is a common question yeah or
yawns like you're pulling this from one
of the previous tests okay bob says two
to the power of 12 he's using to solve
as homework haha yeah that's right
Collette you you know okay yeah but but
just in general just to kind of mention
something to you guys is that this is
just testing you on the rules of
exponents so if the bases are the same
right and you're dividing then you
subtract the exponents yeah so Bob's
saying just write it as 2 cubed right 8
is 2 cubed and then over here like that
and then power to power you multiply
right so that's going to be 2 to the 3x
and then when you divide what do you do
you subtract right okay and then
okay so then what you have here now is
you've got two to the 3x minus y power
but since that equals 12 you can write
that as 2 to the 12th so I hope that
helps Jake but yeah basically the key is
to get the base is the same you know and
then know all your rules of exponents so
like when you multiply you know you add
the exponents when you have a power to
power your x and then when you divide
you subtract so yeah so other questions
other things you guys want to ask me any
other questions so what do you think Oh
Collette yay sorry okay you're asking
what's the difference between
permutation and combination okay that's
a good question so okay so are you guys
familiar with this notation and P R and
NC are you guys familiar with this so a
permutation the order matters
combination the order doesn't matter
right so the example would be like this
like say for example you have like say
there's ten people in your in your class
okay it's a small class right and say
you're gonna pick a president and a vice
president does the order matter or does
it not matter the order matter or does
it not matter so 10 people in your class
yeah you can use it on your calculator
too that's a good point Bob but let's
just see if we can get the set up so do
you think like the order matters like if
you're gonna pick yeah you can do the
factorial thing by hand that's true so
the thing is though so with permutations
the question was what's the difference
between combinations okay so yeah so
basically the permutation is the order
matters combination doesn't matter so to
go back to our example if there's ten
people in your class and you're gonna
pick a president and a vice president
the order matters you want to use the P
for permutations if you were just gonna
pick two co-captains out of ten right
then you're gonna use a combinations ten
see two and just like Bob was saying you
can just type this in on your calculator
ten P two and find out the number of
ways of picking a president a vice
president over here ten see two okay
you're going to be finding out the you
know the number of ways of
just picking two people or the order
doesn't matter so again I think I'll
just kind of leave it at that you know
you can use your calculator on these on
these types of problems to solve so so
does that answer your question kolache
so okay so other questions everything is
you want to ask about of course you know
the thing is is that you know with the
ECT and SCT that what are they testing
us on basically pre-algebra algebra
algebra to write trig geometry you know
and so there's a little bit you know
from each of those different areas so oh
let's see Bravo bomb I missed your
question let me go back let's see try to
get everyone's questions if I can where
I lost that which word oh how would I
improve on problems where you have to
come up with an equation is that the one
you're asking about is that the one you
meant so yes I mean that's a difficult
one too okay Bob is asking about
sohcahtoa and okay oh I guess maybe I
didn't see that one can you ask me that
question again broth Obama how to use
trigonometric ratios with the unit
circle okay so you're asking about the
unit circle trig ratios well that's a
that's a big topic I don't know if I can
really explain explain that too much I
mean that's
you can check I've got a video on that
all about the unit circle mastered the
unit circle my youtube channel Mars math
tutoring I probably go over there that's
probably got a better explanation that I
can do for you right now just because it
would take quite a bit yeah so those are
the basic ones Bob like let's see ziad
is asking what book should I buy if I'm
done with the official SAT tests well
that's a good question you know you can
go over to like it depends that we're
how advanced you are like if you're
really advanced like Barron's usually
has more challenging type problems if
you're kind of middle-of-the-road I
would say like Princeton or Kaplan you
know one of their study guides so I'll
probably check those out
baba says college pandas good for math
ought to check that I have never seen
their stuff okay all right some good
suggestions yeah very good so let's see
so other questions other things you
wanted to ask me about oh you're a smelt
the sohcahtoa okay so yeah so we'll do
some examples with the sohcahtoa because
they add you're welcome
okay good test taking tips you know
that's a good question you know you
there's whole classes devoted to these
test taking tips like you know how to
take the answers and back substitute or
how to eliminate ones that you know that
are not right and you know there's a
whole like strategy behind like kind of
like solving the problems in it without
actually having to solve the problems
and those are definitely valuable you
know like some of these problems like
remember that question that I think Jake
was asking about the system of equations
earlier sometimes you're better off just
back substituting the answer in and
checking you know sometimes that's
faster but you're gonna have to kind of
get that down from experience to see if
you're better off trying to go ahead and
solve it or just trying to take those
answers and back substitute so but as
far as just solving some sohcahtoa type
problems like say for example this is
three and this is like 27 degrees and
this is X like how would you solve for
this missing side rate right here X so
here we're talking a little bit about
the sine cosine and tangent ratios right
so what do you think what what would you
do to solve for that missing side would
be a sine ratio cosine or tangent ratio
hmm you think Bob's the sine of 27
equals 3 over C let's see so let's see
so basically you pretend like you're
standing at the angle at this vertex
here this is the opposite side that's
the hypotenuse is he opposite hypotenuse
that's sine so sine of 27° equals 3 over
X and then what you can do is you can
cross multiply if you want this is one
way to do it so X sine of 27 equals 3
times 1 which is 3 and then divide both
sides by sine of 27 and that's going to
be your answer right there so yeah so
you really want to know these ratios a
sine cosine tangent ratios
other questions yeah other things you
want to talk about other things that you
does everybody know the equation of a
circle that's I mentioned this problem
all the time because you know a lot of
times students they forget this one but
it's it's a super easy question to get
right so I'll just here I'll just give
you an example so if there's other
questions go ahead and put them in the
chat we'll see if we can get to some of
the questions and before we finish up
this live stream but let's see what what
other questions you guys have but I'm
writing down an equation of a circle can
anybody tell me what the center of the
circle is and what the radius of the
circle is radiuses for Bob says okay Z
right and the center is at positive 3
negative 4 okay what do you think is you
right so what do you think so when we're
talking about the equation of a circle
ok broth Obama says yes Katie's right
Collette she says no okay what do you
think it is clutch e is it so just to
kind of a refresher here if there's one
thing that you if there's only one thing
that you memorized out of this entire
live stream remember this because this
this is an easy one to get write the
equation of a circle all right so here's
the center here it's HK and this is your
radius so you can see to get from 16
that's R squared right we actually have
to take the square root so the radius is
going to be 4 and then with the center
see how this is X minus H so it's
actually positive 3 negative 4 and the
radius is going to be the square root of
16 which is 4 so yeah so basically want
to take the square root to get the
radius and oh bob is asking sometimes I
have to complete the square for circle
equations and Klutch uses how do you
deal with this problem with a three
dimensional circle okay you're talking
about like a sphere okay and yeah so
you're not gonna really have to solve
for like a you're not gonna have the
formula for a sphere on the SAT so I
wouldn't worry about that one for right
now so we'll leave that for another you
know another discussion but as far as
completing the square you know that's an
important skill it's definitely
something you want to understand
sometimes they'll give you an equation
it looks something maybe like
like this say for example x squared plus
2x let's see let's see
plus let's see here plus let's say this
is y squared plus 6y plus 4 equals 2
okay I'm just making something up so
what you would have to do is you have to
complete the square you know to put it
in the standard form of the equation of
a circle so you can identify the center
and the radius so yeah so that's
definitely important something important
to to understand completing the square
anybody want to try to solve that one
and and check that with Bob and see if
you guys that got that right
you okay so he's talking about yeah B
over 2 the quantity squared yeah that's
exactly right you got it
so what do you guys think so yeah so
basically what you would want to do is
you want to move these constants to the
other sides I'm going to subtract the 4
that's negative 2 and then over here
let's see we've got okay so now we're
going to study sites doesn't have a lot
of questions asked but I can type them
because so involved oh it's a diagram
yeah yeah those diagram once heard hard
to describe on a chat hmm okay so let's
see so basically what we want to do Bob
was saying you take half of this middle
coefficient so half of 2 is 1 and you
square it which is 1 but if you add it
to the left you have to add that one to
the right to keep it balanced right same
thing over here you take half of 6 which
is 3 and square that which is 9 but you
have to add 9 to the other side to keep
it balanced then what you want to do is
factor this and same thing over here you
want to factor this and then combine
like terms over here so now you can see
the center is going to be what and the
radius is going to be what so I talked
about completing the square in the in
the courses you can check that out if
you want to learn more about the
completing the square process we do a
bunch of examples but here you can see
the center is going to be at negative 1
negative 3 and the radius is going to be
the square root of 8 and you can
simplify that down ok clutch e how do
you graph a quadratic equation yeah
Bob's square root of 8 so when you say
quadratic equation can you be more
specific so if you guys can be more
specific with your questions I'll be
able to help out a little bit better you
know if you have a more specific
question quadratic equations you know
what quadratic equations are our
quadratic equations are our equations
that have that squared right yeah you
can graph it on your calculus a good
suggestion you can always graph them on
your calculator but yeah that's kind of
a big topic I need a little bit more
specific on that yeah you can find the
vertex and find the zeros 2x squared
minus 4x plus 6 ok let's see 2x squared
minus 4x plus 6
you wanted to graph this
well okay so this this one here is what
they call yet Bob saying a y-intercept
of six that's right and how do you find
the vertex what's the key to finding the
vertex of this parabola
well yeah negative B over 2a that's
right for the x-coordinate okay goodbye
Bob you're Bob you're really sharp you
got this town really good okay and their
parabola is going up or downward
depending on the x-value yeah so
basically this coefficient here a if
it's positive it means it's opening up
if it's negative its opening down that's
exactly right you guys are on this but
to find the vertex you know you can use
the completing the square process that's
one way to do this okay but it's easy
just to use this formula here negative B
over 2a okay so what you're going to
want to do is take the opposite of B so
the opposite of negative 4 is positive 4
over 2 times a which is 2 right so that
comes out to what that's 1 right so then
move this up here a little bit so if you
put one back into your equation here
you're going to get the y coordinate of
the vertex so that's 2 minus 4 is
negative 2 plus 6 is 4 okay so we're
looking at our vertex is at 1/4 okay and
the y-intercept is that 6 like Bob said
over here so 5 6 and then this is the
axis of symmetry right through the x
coordinate the vertex so if you take the
mirror image of that y-intercept point
you've got another point right there and
you've got your graph so just kind of a
rough rough sketch there ok so you guys
have a lot a lot of great questions so a
lot of a lot of great questions so I
think what I'm gonna do now okay is I'm
just going to kind of mention a couple
couple quick suggestions so one is if
you haven't checked these out yet go
ahead and check it out in the
description the huge a CT math review
video course and my huge SAT math review
video course there's three free previews
over there so you can kind of see what
it's like and see if that's something
you're interested in I highly recommend
them if you guys are in the middle if
you're somewhere at you know getting a
really high score already then you know
these would be kind of more review but
if you're on the lower end of things and
maybe kind of forgot some concepts or
you know there's a lot of things that
you need to review these courses are
going to be excellent so so definitely
check that out and the other thing is is
that if you guys are interested after I
stop this livestream if you want to
continue to help each other in the
comments section of this video that
might be a good resource for you guys
you can you know kind of ask each other
questions help each other out so I
definitely recommend that but other than
that thanks for joining me today and if
you haven't subscribed to the channel if
you're interested I've also got tons of
videos on my Mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel so check that out for
more help you know if you're looking for
some help in your math class or help
with a CT SAT and I think if you're
interested in online tutoring can also
reach me for that if you're interested
in doing an online session we can set
that up you can contact me through my
website Mario's math tutoring com and I
think that's about it so great job
thanks for being here and good luck when
you take the tests if you need to reach
out to me you can do so otherwise I'll
talk to you next time
you